right now as a man who's been inside
Pittsburgh sports since 1983 he's been
on the Steelers beat since 85 and on the
Pro Football Hall of Fame board of
selectors he said boo said of the
Pittsburgh post-gazette how you doing ed
I'm great rich hey thanks for having me
on
no you bet thanks for thanks for joining
there's so many questions I get asked
about the Steelers and and I'm gonna
just go right in on the first one does
Big Ben still really want to play
football dad yeah I think so
you know you had that moment in the
spring when he wondered whether he
should retire or not his his wife wants
him to retire easier said he's look at
the CTE studies but then he committed to
this season and yeah I think he wants to
play I can't tell you how long I can't
tell you if he this is his last year or
not but he wants to play this year yes
yeah I mean he's he's he's IIIi think
he's given it as all if that's what you
know you mean no I don't think it's it's
it's it's easy giving it his all and the
question it's just you know when things
are difficult to explain that's when the
conspiracy stuff creeps in and not just
sports but in life and the offense with
Big Ben and Belle and Brown have yet to
truly consistently click in a manner
that we have become used to it and
certainly fantasy football players
demand it and and and part of the
reasoning that might be is just that
that Ben is not as into it anymore that
he might even though he's trying his
hardest mentally he might not be all in
bed yeah III know what you're saying
rich and he does take some of the blame
for the offense it has taken some of the
blame for the offense not producing as
hey everyone expected you me them and
but there are others there are others
there's been a lot of meanie stuff this
year Antonio Brown throwing a fit in
Baltimore because he was open and they
didn't roll it to him
you know packing a water-cooler lady on
bail said they didn't run the ball and
off at one point
martavis Bryant has asked to be traded
you know there's a lot of stuff going on
and there's a lot of besides been
missing some open receivers some open
receivers have also failed to catch the
ball or failed to run the right route
the offensive line hasn't lived up to
expectations
Le'Veon Bell whose average you know four
six four five four seven a carry is
averaging three point eight right now so
there's a lot of dysfunction if you will
on this offense and I don't think it
just comes down to the quarter of
adverse yet of the Pittsburgh
post-gazette here on the Honda inside a
report on the Rich Eisen show so I guess
a private moment when you're if you're
speaking to coaches players what
concerns this Steelers team the most as
they get set for their final seven games
of the season yeah I don't think there's
a believe it or not I don't think
there's a concern so much is they just
want to get this offense going
their defense rich has transitioned
nicely from they had some really great
defenses with Paul Amato and those guys
in the you know from 2005 to maybe 2012
I think they were number one three or
four years went to three Super Bowls and
won two of them but those guys all got
old fast and they transitioned they kept
draft and you know high guys putting
them in and and they have a nice nice
defense now and in a way the defense has
been really carrying the water for the
offense it is under you know under
played if you will underperformed but
they're still they still have hope that
you know they're all healthy they're all
back from the offense that was great
before yeah and and juju Smith Shuster
has been added to it I mean this kid is
about a revelation and nationally yet
he's just been a delight to follow his
exploits with his bicycle and his
driver's license and the the touchdown
celebrations how has he been playing
here local
and in that locker room even better um
he is the real thing I mean he's he's a
delight that's a word teammates coaches
and media used to describe him rich he's
he's you know he's the youngest guy in
the league I didn't forget what date I
think it's a little later so he's not
old enough to have a beer yet but he
just got his driver's license al
Villanueva was teaching him how to drive
their left tackle their army veteran um
it's just been a great story with him
you know he lost that bike he stole the
bike and uh often news channels were
paddle on our paper had Ilan and within
a couple days a bike was returned to him
do we know who took the bike no well
some guy bought it off a guy in a street
for 200 bucks and he took it home and he
saw these news stories and he I guess he
called up to either the cops or the or
the Steelers and said hey I just bought
his bike you can have it back and he
gave it back I heard that ending of that
story pretty good story
yeah thanks Berg you know get that why
it's well that's the beauty of it it's
it this is such a small you know big
town you know I mean where you know I
found out Billy Gardell was in town
because people you know we're telling me
about it on the streets right I mean and
how I'm serious and how and how what
this team means to this city and then
obviously you know what the Penguins
have been doing here certainly of late
and I'm just wondering where where you
think this team is headed right I mean
and and where you think this Steelers
team is is possibly going to go this
year best you can tell and having seen
it all from the grassroots up IDI rich
I'm glad you threw that word in possibly
because we're headed there possibly
headed to the Super Bowl because they
have everything going for them
I mean past performance aside from the
offense this offense is still has it has
a leading NFL's leading rusher the NFL's
leading receiver a veteran
offensive line a one of the top
quarterbacks in the game you know that
the the young rookie who was just
capturing every everything and martavis
Bryant he may snap out of it and if he
does that'll that'll really help this
offense and they play five at the next
seven at Hall including the big one
against New England
so they've underperformed you know they
they got a scare in Indianapolis last
Sunday but they pulled it out and it's
it's still alright there for them
well last one four-year dead Bichette
Pittsburgh post-gazette in the Honda
inside a report is I think Mike Tomlin
doesn't get nearly enough credit for
being coach of the year type stuff and
you know you mentioned Al Villanueva we
you know it's been weeks it feels like
it's been a year since that moment where
he came out in the tunnel in Chicago and
then was right in the middle of the
national anthem conversation and the
team and what it really was trying to do
and what it was what was happening in
the locker room was a part of a
conversation you mentioned martavis
bryant you mentioned how big ven and
Antonio Brown had words in a way through
the media after he pitched that fit on
the sidelines what does Mike Tomlin do
to keep everything in-house what do you
see personally about how he goes about
his business you know here's a way to
prod guys and get I think get the best
out of them now he you know I think with
another coach this thing might be spiral
model out of control but he he's really
respected by by them and has been you
know he's in his a little season now and
I've never seen him lose a team
I've seen him stolen four and not lose a
team he's he he gets it he knows what
buttons to push on each individual
player as a team you know I've been
around Chuck Noll and Bill Cowher
covered both of them and you know each
have their different ways but I I put
him
right up there I really do is a really
good coach that really appreciate the
time we'll see you we'll see you around
here tonight in Heinz Field thanks for
calling all right good to be on with you
you bet that said Bush out of the
Pittsburgh post-gazette
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience